j'accueille stéphane guillon
comment ça va
[Applaudissements]
bien sécher
on commence par la politique dans le
figaro ségolène royal est comparé à
hillary clinton donc clinton c'est
françois hollande dans ce cas qui fait
monica levinsky c'est typique du figaro
ils ne vont jamais au bout de leur
raisonnement dans libération une lettre
de dominique voynet à nicolas hulot tu
es des nôtres c'est pas juste tu tries
telle ordure tu économises l'eau tu
mange bio et au final qui reçoit une
déclaration de dominique voynet ça donne
envie d'acheter un 4 4 diesel
le ministère de la santé s'intéressent
aux produits ou choya le spray à base de
limonène provoque des cancers chez le
rat qui va aller parfumé 1re avec un
déodorant le choix on n'est pas content
dominique voynet au coeur de ses poils
au bras pataugas
une info du parisien un des fils de
philippe de villiers mise en examen pour
viols sur son frère cadet c'est embêtant
philippe de villiers le garant de la
famille modèle si ces enfants ce violent
entre eux c'est comme si le pen héberger
des sans papiers comme si dieudonné
jouait son spectacle en israël on perd
nos repères et en même temps élevé en
vendée par philippe de villiers seule
sortie de l'année le puy du fou est ce
que tu ne finis pas par te taper ton
frère
[Applaudissements]
politique internationale une exposition
sur les droits de l'homme à pékin en
chine si j'avais évité tiananmen la
torture et il ya aussi la peine de mort
3500 fusillé par an 3500 sait pas grand
chose on ça fait un dixième du parc des
princes à peine disons le virage nord on
n'a qu'à supprimer les plus cons
un remake de flipper le dauphin flipper
et poutine poutine zigouille des
journalistes torture des tchétchènes et
flipper s'en branle
après les dauphins les poissons lune
evelyne thomas a été frappé par son mari
christophe oui c'est son choix de lui en
mettre une
prudence quand même le botox plus des
beignes elle va bientôt ressembler
adjani dans mary stuart
un ange passe
société inauguration d'une stèle pour
les victimes du concorde le 25 juillet
2000 113 retraités allemands partent
pour les caraïbes une arrivée inattendue
à gonesse un hôtel miteux des valises
éventré pack clim une température de 300
degrés la femme de chambre absente
soi-disant écrasé par un réacteur
manifestation devant le siège des
surgelés picard s'ils se mettent en
grève
attention plus de surgelés ça veut dire
plus de place dans le congélateur des
ménagères et toutes les naissances à
venir
une info paris match les femmes ont pris
le pouvoir sans doute mais il y en a pas
une qui est [ __ ] 1-1
peut-être la grande à gauche non
[Rires]
télévision les papilles flics en fin de
course faut pas exagérer un navarro perd
sa prostate a fait 45 % de part de
marché
merci ces gens
oui porno à la télé le csa interdit les
films x sans capote son parent a causé
ça on peut déjà plus boire plus fumer
prendre une fille à moitié bourré de
clope au bec ça a son charme
dans vsd des photos très dur
d'américains mutilés et un français vous
reconnaissez les béquilles ce sont
celles de michel drucker
bah oui j'y peux rien pendant quatre
pages olga sa chienne témoigne mon
maître est un grand angoissé michel n'a
pas fait le vietnam l'irak mais le rtf
et visiblement ça laisse des séquelles
un peu de douceur maintenant ma
sélection de noël pour les petites
filles sortie du livre officiel miss
france on apprend qu'à l'hôpital le
sourire de miss france aide les enfants
dans leur guérison ouais moi j'aurais
plutôt peur que ça les achève fillette
si on top ce manuel appel carole bouquet
enfance maltraitée
un spécialiste du billard créé un jeu de
boules à l'éffigie de nos politiques
pour tous ceux qui rêvent de mettre un
coup de queue à ségolène royal
le jeu idéal jouait toujours pour les
déguisements de monstres choisissez hulk
capitaine crochet au dark vador le pen
dieudonné et georges frêche c'est de
très mauvais goût enfin barbie sort son
coffret mamie le problème c'est son prix
mais bon avec vous avez 17 de pièces
jaunes le château de bity un compte au
japon
1 semaine prochaine merci beaucoup
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
1h10 tube abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou